you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news live from cop26 in glasgow
today
big moves on the most polluting fossil
fuel as countries set out how they plan
to end coal power after 250 years
but not in china which burns more of the
fossil fuel than the rest of the world
combined we report on the zombie coal
power stations being fired up once
again in russia there's little talk of
the climate crisis or cop26 for those
whose livelihoods depend on the oil and
gas are still at the heart of russia's
economy
and powering the green revolution we
meet the apprentice wind turbine
technician helping inspire others to
make a difference
[Music]
hello and welcome to the daily climate
show live from the heart of the cop26
summit in glasgow and it's been an
important day here with the focus being
on energy more than 40 countries signed
up to a statement committing to phase
out coal power in the next two decades
and 20 nations agreed to cut off public
financing for fossil fuel projects
abroad by the end of next year diverting
cash into clean energy instead
the influential head of the
international energy agency says that
new climate promises made during the
cop26 summit
could bring global warming down to 1.8
degrees above pre-industrial levels but
there are concerns the most polluting
countries just aren't doing enough our
climate change correspondent thomas
peter has more and a warning her report
contains some flash photography
today at cop 26 it's all about energy
the end of coal is in sight
a slew of pledges to transition away
from coal in particular as well as oil
and gas
the headlines are good but there are
notable absences from the big polluters
russia's name does not appear on any of
those agreements
why not
russia believes that the energy
transition should be
smooth in order to prevent any kind of
economic shocks and
the reason uh the the recent energy
crisis uh in the world vividly
demonstrates that we need to uh approach
steadily uh the energy transition and
you are perfectly aware of the structure
of the russian economy and how uh large
our country is and i would like to uh
tell you that we are not living in a
fairy tale and it is impossible to deal
with this complex issue very fast and
in one day or a year
australia too one of the world's largest
producers of coal unwilling to join the
consensus despite the royal treatment
it is absolutely in defiance of reality
i mean the world has got is going to get
off coal and gas
and if we don't start getting off it
ourselves we're going to have a lot of
stranded assets we'll have coal mines
and gas fields for which there are no
customers
us energy secretary jennifer granholm
hopes the prospect of an economic
nightmare will eventually be enough to
persuade the reluctant away from fossil
fuels both abroad and at home we all
have to do our part to move toward clean
right and so the build-up of fossil
fuels inside of all of our countries
has to be overcome by the buildup of
clean and i'm very bullish on what that
looks like in terms of clean energy
economy etc i'm hopeful that our
our global counterparts see that
opportunity as well
right now that is no more than a hope
but there have been steps forward today
at cop26
perhaps not giant leaps but progress
nonetheless
well hannah is here with me now so
hannah two new agreements on coal today
after a sprinkling of announcements
during the week so so far is cot 26
proving to be a success well one of the
other things that caught people's eye
today anna is that a commitment from
america to join a group of countries
that are promising to stop investing in
fossil fuel projects overseas now
america is a really big spender one of
the largest finances of overseas fossil
fuel projects in the world and so that's
really significant although there has
been a little bit of criticism that that
group didn't include any asian countries
and no china no south korea no japan
that's a problem
but you know more broadly it is starting
to feel according to the experts that
what is happening here is having an
impact the international energy agency
has just suggested that if all of the
pledges made at this conference actually
happen that's a big if but let's pretend
they do then global warming could be
limited to 1.8 degrees of warming of our
pre-industrial times now that is inching
perhaps closer to keeping 1.5 degrees of
warming within reach which is the
overarching aim of this summit
absolutely hannah thanks very much
indeed
now one of the notable exceptions to the
pledge to end the use of coal was china
and that's seen as a big issue because
the country is a huge consumer of the
fossil fuel
well last year china was the only g20
country to see a large increase in coal
generation rising by 1.7
but globally in 2020 coal generation had
its biggest fall on record leaving china
with an increasing share up from 44
in 2015 to 53 in 2020
and between 2015 and 2020 electricity
demand grew by over
1880 terawatt hours in the country with
growing demand for electricity both
renewable and non-renewable generation
has had to increase and that means more
power plants depending on coal as tom
cheshire reports from ning wu in the
mining province of shanxi
welcome to china's coal country
the impact of all this isn't just being
felt here but by the planet itself
coal is the dirtiest fossil fuel around
and china burns more of it than the rest
of the world combined and it's speeding
up
we've taken a road trip to shenshi
province north china to understand it
better
it's a place where almost everything is
caked in grime and soot but it's the
scale that's astonishing
we visit three coal power plants within
a few hours drive of each other
they're under construction or adding
extra power and between them alone
represent more coal power than the
entire uk output
and what's more they nearly weren't
built
they were all halted a few years ago
under a national directive to restrict
coal power only to resume construction
what this is is zombie coal power killed
off back in 2017 but now being brought
stumbling back to life ready to spew
harmful gases into the air and china
can't or won't kill it off for good
ningwoo town is attached to one of the
mines and heavily reliant on the
industry
people are too busy trying to survive
the coming winter to even know about
cop26
i'm waiting here by school because more
people pass by
my whole family
my son my daughter and i we've sold coal
our whole lives
sir buys coal from nearby mines then
drives into town to sell it from the
back of his van to people here to burn
for heat
because of shortages and coal being
diverted to heavy industry mines have
less to spare sometimes he now has to
wait two days at a mine to fill up his
van we asked him what he thought of
china's climate emission targets and cop
26.
i don't know i'm busy every day
i earn my living by working outside all
day long
even chinese climate experts don't
believe it's practical for the country
to cut its co-dependence in the short
term
this isn't about the gap between pledges
and reality between high-level
international summits and the truth on
the ground
this is the pledge the one china has
made officially to build more and more
coal power for the next four years and
then reduce it only gradually
they have not said how they will do that
or how long it will take
and in that uncertainty that hesitation
hangs the future of our climate tom
cheshire sky news shanxi china
well it's not just coal which is
contributing to climate change other
fossil fuels like oil and gas are also
huge contributors and russia is still a
huge producer and consumer of them both
well our moscow correspondent diana
magnay reports now from surgut in
siberia
[Applause]
drive through western siberia and you
pass one oil installation after the next
in the swampy ground the pipelines which
form the veins and arteries of russia's
economy
this is oil and gas central russian
hydrocarbons for delivery worldwide and
not much sense of the climate emergency
russian energy giant rosneft has
facilities everywhere it's their key oil
producing region and everywhere we see
flares
that's methane burnt off rather than
stored or reprocessed
it's not as bad as releasing it pure but
still it's a major source of co2 with
quite a bit of methane still mixed in
rosneft has promised to end all flaring
by 2030 as part of an impressive
sounding sustainability strategy
but that is still a long way from
reality and that's really russia's story
with so much oil gas and coal still to
extract for decades to come
what will those promises look like in 10
20 30 years time
pipes laid in soviet times now rusting
no longer in use
the evidence of past oil spills still
plain to see across scarred earth and
dead trees but then there are the leaks
that we cannot see
methane escaping from damaged pipes or
faulty storage tanks or vented
deliberately at huge environmental cost
rosneft's local securities stop us at a
checkpoint and then tail us for hours
not keen on us filming even from public
roads why are you following us all the
time
russia is the number one flaring culprit
by far and you can see that from the
satellite data
this tool from flair analytics firm
capterio can track any flare anywhere
and measure its emissions yeah so
flaring venting and leaking put together
for rushes probably of the order of 1.4
billion co2 equivalent times so that's
equivalent to probably about 50 million
u.s passenger vehicles being taken off
the road by solving this problem
petrochemical companies like sibor
provide one solution taking these gases
and processing them turning them into
polymers which are the feedstock for
plastics
um
[Music]
is a green pioneer setting out ambitious
climate targets and investing heavily in
low carbon technologies
but if russia is to hit net zero by 2060
the rest of the country needs to catch
up
in the oil capital sorghut we meet some
young recruits for the local oil firm on
a team building exercise pretending to
be oil pumps
and they aren't too worried about our
warming planet
but the methane leaks from russia's oil
and gas industry are just a fraction of
what we burn using the energy that it
produces
and if global demand stays strong the
sun setting on russian hydrocarbons
looks like it's a long long way off
down in magnesium
well let's take a look now some of the
day's other climate news from cop26 and
from around the world and scientists
have warned that global carbon pollution
is expected to return to almost
pre-pandemic levels this year emissions
from fossil fuels fell 5.4 in 2020 from
a record high the previous year but
research from the annual global carbon
budget shows they're expected to rise by
4.9 in 2021 to around 0.8 below 2019
levels
the number of homes listed for sale with
an electric car charging point nearby
has increased
541 percent over the past year property
website rightmove also said a third of
homes added to the website since
september mention electric car charging
facilities
protesters dressed as pokemon character
pikachu have gathered in glasgow to
demand japan stops funding overseas coal
projects and commits to phasing out
domestic coal use by 2030. despite its
net zero by 2050 pledge japan hasn't
revealed any plans to end coal use in
its power mix
and the protest group insulate britain
were in westminster today where they
blocked two roads around parliament
square some demonstrators sat in the
road with banners while others glued
themselves to the ground the house of
commons speaker sir lindsey doyle
accused the group of interfering with
democracy after the hold-ups prevented
an mp from asking a minister a question
now while a lot of the focus here at
kopp is on countries and their
commitments those making a difference on
a smaller scale are also being
celebrated one step greener ambassadors
have been working with summit organizers
to inspire others to make changes to
help the planet
one of those is jasmine allen an
apprentice wind turbine technician
[Music]
i love my job because
i get to do something that is
contributing to a better future
[Music]
i think that everything i have the
opportunity to learn as exciting as the
technology is constantly changing so
everything is always new and you face
different challenges every day
[Music]
it's important to make a change so that
generations after us
still can have a brighter greener future
my advice would be to get involved take
the steps to make a difference
well joining me now to discuss the
climate issues of the day are acting
director at the energy and climate
intelligence unit sepi golzari monroe
and professor of energy policy at
university college london jim watson so
just the man for this question uh
obviously the focus was energy today but
the main announcements were focusing on
coal one of the four priorities that
boris johnson has set out coming into
this summit so how big a deal were those
announcements it is a big deal i mean
it's partly because we've got more
countries on board as well as actually
regions within countries so i watched
some of the plenary speeches on this and
it was really striking to get not only
national governments on the stage with
companies and then representatives at
areas such as silesia and poland which
is very dependent on coal mining and so
it's significant to get more of them in
with plans to get away from coal with
plans to stop financing coal in other
countries and some quite surprising
additions like vietnam like chile middle
income countries who've really struggled
to get past coal for quite a long time
and and you feel that that's starting to
tip with all these announcements you're
going to have to see is it going to be
implemented the devil's in the detail
etc but i think it's very hopeful and
also emissions notable emissions as well
aren't there i mean on the deal to ditch
coal you didn't get some of the biggest
coal producers you didn't get australia
or china you didn't get the us or india
i mean
does it mean much when you haven't got
those countries on board it still means
something but the absence of those
countries is really important as well
and we really want uh china uh to come
on board for example uh india and the
u.s that is really important and and and
it's a problem that they're not there i
was really struck by something the uk
energy minister said that actually to
get away from coal we need to start
closing two large coal-fired power
stations a week now interestingly for
years we've been saying china has been
opening two for two large coal-fired
power stations a week and it kind of
reminded me that about their absence and
the fact that they really need to join
and join this movement in the next five
years or so uh to really make it
meaningful and sophie it was interesting
wasn't it because there were a lot of
new countries to join this pledge i
think more than 20 new countries and
jim has mentioned some of them indonesia
vietnam and also poland as well and i
was watching some of those sessions as
well and one of the representatives from
indonesia saying yeah we're on track we
really want to do this but we need money
we need help and that's a big issue
isn't it it's knowing that that money
will be forthcoming so that they can
make this transition that's right and i
think
our model to look at here is actually
the deal that was done for south africa
which is going to be providing 8.5
trillion dollars of finance over four
years to help the south africans move
away from coal but to move away from
coal in a way that actually provides
security and a just transition for the
workers in that country well that's
right because that's one of the real
concerns isn't it seppi that this is
obviously that the ambition is to to
save the planet to keep global warming
down but there are individuals involved
here who work in these fossil fuel
sectors you must be quite worried when
they hear announcements like this
exactly and i think that that's why it's
so important to work with countries and
to make sure that countries themselves
that are planning to do this have got a
means of engaging
the people whose lives this transition
is going to affect because frankly you
know you need to make sure that people
have that security in moving towards a
decarbonized world do you think that
south africa deal gym is a model that we
might see rolled out in other parts of
the world where money is directly given
in climate aid to a particular purpose
i.e phasing out cold do you see that
happening elsewhere i do i do and i
think the indonesia case which has been
mentioned is another important one i
mean through some of the programs i work
with with the uk foreign commonwealth
and development office if i can say
their full name um you know we we engage
with our counterparts in places like
indonesia and it's very clear that they
see a path to change but actually that
will require that finance and that other
technological help to be able to do it
it's not that it can't happen but those
things are an important condition to be
able to do that and and so we've got in
these announcements we've had
announcements through the week we've had
a pledge to reduce methane emissions
sepi we've had a pledge to protect
forests as well i mean what's your
impression do you get the feeling that
things are heading in the right
direction does cops start feeling like a
success to you
i have to say i do feel quite optimistic
about this cop so far we of course don't
want to speak too soon but i really like
to take a step back and say well
actually it was only six short years ago
that the world was on a path to six
degrees of warming that's obviously very
dangerous then after the paris agreement
we were on a trajectory for four degrees
still still very troubling and in that
time in six short years just before we
started this conference we were on a 2.7
degree trajectory now five days into the
conference with the pledges that have
been made by countries and these deals
that have been done outside of the
formal negotiations we're potentially
looking at having closed the gap to 1.8
1.9 degrees now that's critical that
shows that actually these conferences
they do work they need the public
pressure from the outside but they do
work year on year they build on it and
they turn the political temperature up
to keep global warming down and that 1.8
figure is what's been put forward by the
iea the director of the iea fatty beryl
today the international energy agency i
mean very respected organization jim so
but then again presumably there are a
load of caveats this is if the pledges
are met if it's one thing pledging
something but some of these pledges
don't have detailed plans behind them i
mean are you confident that the pledges
that have been made can be delivered
i think partially confident you're
absolutely right i mean fatty bureau
kept his team up all night i think doing
that we've got some former colleagues of
mine work there and they said they were
working very hard to kind of just get a
sense of it and to come to that 1.8
degree result but they're are huge
caveats about deliverability and
measurement whether you're talking the
methane deal being able to deliver that
you know that requires you for example
to monitor everything from agriculture
emissions from brazil to long-distance
pipelines for gas from russia into
europe and those are notoriously leaky
and difficult to manage so there's lots
of questions underneath but i do share
the optimism that actually you know we
are starting to see these big
cross-cutting deals in big chunks of the
areas of emissions and if they're
delivered we are getting much closer to
where we need to be and what i would add
to that is actually what these
conferences need to continue to do it
doesn't mean that you know job done you
know we're on a good trajectory let's go
home actually year on year the task now
is to make sure countries come back to
the table that they are actually
delivering on their promises so that
needs to be monitored year on year this
is a purpose for the climate conferences
going forward and the public pressure
for that is there and will continue to
be there but actually also making sure
that the private sector deals and the
broader multilateral deals that have
been made alongside the formal
negotiations are also being delivered so
that is a job for year on year to come
back and make sure that we're delivering
on these promises do you think that'll
be agreed because we've got greta
thunderberg once again a little bit
skeptic skeptical about all this she's
she's tweeted talking about greenwashing
when when it comes to these
announcements i mean people have her
promises before haven't they i mean and
you need to take people with you don't
you yes you do you do and i my sort of
natural innate optimism about all this
is tempered a little i mean it's a long
time since i've been to a copy over a
decade but this does feel different
partly because the solutions are there
and demonstrated you know the costs of
renewable energy have tumbled you're
starting to see cheaper electricity
storage you're seeing countries move in
ways that they didn't 10 years ago but
she is absolutely right you need to hold
feet to the fire and that's through the
public pressure you mentioned and if
that isn't there and you don't come back
year after year to make sure it's done
then you know we will go home and then
wonder what's happened the next time we
all get together we must leave it there
jim watson steppi goldzari monroe thanks
both very much indeed
don't forget you can listen to a new
climate cast a podcast every day from
cop 26 wherever you normally get your
podcast from and you may well already be
watching this on our pop-up channel but
if you're not you can find uninterrupted
coverage from cop26 between 9am and 7pm
on the channel 525 all week thanks for
watching see you tomorrow
[Music]